[Music]
what do you mean there's no transitional
hybrids what does that mean we have not
found any intermediate or transitional
hybrids in Europe in other words
humanely found anything
well you might we find skulls we find
skeletons we find bones right fossils
and either they're human
totally human or they're totally nano
though you don't find like an Al
Hathaway there's no halfway you would
think that if they made it for anywhere
between forty to eighty thousand years
ago even if they only made it for five
thousand years right that we would find
you know some kind of transitional
fossils were what the little kid is born
from from the two species or the two
races in this case right and he's got
you know maybe a thick forehead big nose
or some combination you don't see that
this or that it's black or white it's
it's not there's no hybrids so isn't
that because we fought to a few
skeletons
well yeah you found to a few skulls but
you would think that yeah that's
possibly part of the problem but you
would think that at some point we find
some intermediates cause in fact we do
have a case here and as Kinko's he's a
fanatic pursuer this admixture theory
and they wrote a paper his route and
wrote a paper at 1999 party and he says
the mandibular momentum awesome and the
dental size and proportions etc etc etc
align the skeleton with early modern
humans this is a little boy toddler they
found in Portugal right and in that same
report they say body proportions
reflected in by more of tibial links and
died Physiol robusticity etc etc are
lying the skeleton when and of us in
other words they say it's got some
features of humans it's got some
features of
that's what they're seeing in their
report and so this ah here we found a
hybrid a mixture between races right a
lot of people question that the first
problem is this child is only twenty
four thousand years old that's sixteen
thousand years after I am determined
that you know and offals disappeared
which is forty thousand years ago so
it's like a little too late to have a
half-breed yeah that's what did you the
other one is that people who you know
other comment artists who looked at the
samples reach a different conclusion and
they say that the this Portugal child is
really a human you know it's got a they
claim it's got no features of nanda
though whatsoever and here's the same
year 1989 Tattersall he he kind of puts
this all in perspective
he says the foul he says claims for
evidence of transition between nfl's and
mothers based on supposedly intermediate
fossils dating from a short window time
around 40 to 30 thousand years ago have
been refuted by the recognition that the
fossils concerned are either typically
an and Ethel or modern and here these
are for mandibles okay the ones on the
left are human the ones on the right are
nano dog and what you'll notice that
there's no chin the chin you know this
little entry here you know the entry
here you don't see it in the nanotubes
and the kid of the logged are bellow
child one from Portugal he's got the
chin yo Iraq he's a paleontologist and
in the year 2000 a History Channel he
says very clearly the following is that
what we see in Canada though especially
the face we see a quite a unique
morphology this is very different than
what we see in homo sapiens
yeah the thumbs evolve a very peculiar
and very unique anatomy that makes them
very easy to distinguish primarily we
are talking about differences in the
face and of those developed a very
unique facial architecture
it says if somebody took the face and
pulled them out and the rest of the face
is stretching behind
this provides the neanderthal face with
a very unique appearance another thing
is that is very distinct in homo sapiens
is the fact that we do have a chin this
protuberance here is very unique to Homo
sapiens and is absent completely from
the mandible bone and results so that's
it yeah so and you can see these picture
there you know that the child in
Portugal has a chin and I think that's
the you know the straw that breaks the
camel's back this is a human child it's
too late in time it's got a chin Kouga
so what do you think of the retards from
say that their great-grandmother's slept
with an amethyst well let me tell you
what I think
[Music]
you